-We are back with Will Smith.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Since Will stars in "Aladdin,"
he and I are going to face off
in the world's first ever
magic carpet race.
-Yeah! Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Are you ready for this?
-Yeah!
-Wow!
-Yeah! You're going down, son.
[ Cheers and applause ]
All right.
Here's how it's going to work.
We'll be riding these
one-of-a-kind magic carpet
scooters...
[ Laughter ]
-Yes.
-...while wearing our Will Smith
Genie helmets.
Will and I will head out
these doors.
We're gonna say hello to
Aladdin,
who is stealing a loaf of bread
from the marketplace.
[ Laughter ]
-Yes.
-And watch out for those
merchants throwing apples.
You don't want to get hit
with an apple.
-Yeah.
-Then were going to head
to the elevator bank and go
around the belly dancer...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...guarding his hidden treasure.
Then we go down the hallway,
fly into the sky,
all while dodging birds
and mountaintops.
-Yes.
-We'll take a right,
and try to make our way
through the desert sandstorm.
-Along the way, we have to pick
up three flags
in our helmet's color.
You can't win if you don't get
all three of your flags.
Once you cross the finish line,
put your flags in the bowl,
ring the bell.
-Flags in a bowl.
-Will, are you ready for this?
-Yes, I'm ready!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm ready.
[ Drum roll ]
-Higgins, count us down.
-Gentlemen, are you ready to
fly?
-Yes! Yes!
-3, 2, 1, fly!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ "Aladdin"-inspired music
plays ]
-Left.
-Oh, that's nasty.
Oh, that's nasty.
-That's right.
Drink it in, Will.
-That's nasty.
-Drink it in, Will.
That's right.
Try and find my treasure.
Can't touch this.
♪♪♪♪
-Oh!
Oh! Ow! Ow!
-Oh! Oh!
-Wait. [ Laughs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh! Oh! Oh!
Oh! Oh! Oh! Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Music ends ]
-Oh, my God.
-Oh, geez.
-"Aladdin" opens in theaters
everywhere May 24th!